[Music]
honey I just ruined our future I [ __ ]
over our 401k to go to crypto land I
bought a big plot of land on cryptoland
and that [ __ ] sucks
well it looks like we're gonna be
working till we're dead
everybody is here
hi Mr Adams nice to see you sir
oh yes excellent thanks for asking this
is so dumb because you don't do any of
this in a digital space you don't sit on
a [ __ ] airplane imagine exactly [ __ ]
this is all because they don't
want you to go on a real vacation it's
the system they're trying to get you to
own less exactly they don't want you to
dream about owning anything in the real
world also it wouldn't it it would
appear like you know that the character
would look like a woman but it would a
real experience would be for sure a guy
being that girl being like yeah dude are
my tits sick
welcome to crypto land you want to suck
on these boobies well you can't
they're my boobies
also like the experience of checking
into a hotel is always shitty I picture
this guy walking up to this and be like
hey I'm checking in she's like great
what's your name uh Steven whatever
Steven okay
oh so it looks like you booked the ocean
view Suite but we we actually double
booked you we've actually relocated you
to the Ramada Inn just down the block
but you have a view of the pool it's
beautiful it's just as good as crypto
land it's our sister property you'll be
refunded for the price difference
exactly he's like is there anything is
really is there anything you can do let
me check
no
I don't get it it's a digital room how
do you double book a digital room it's
very busy right now sir you came during
the season so sorry it's like [ __ ]
okay how far is the Ramada
it's 45 minutes via Uber local taxi
actually wait so you're saying I have to
sit for 45 minutes in a local taxi in
the metaverse
again you came during the hot season sir
I mean what else did you expect
here are your keys not your keys not
your Bitcoins seriously your keys your
Bitcoin not your keys not your Bitcoins
where do you come up with these crazy
ideas
[Music]
I'm not gonna tell you where uh if
you're on audio holy [ __ ] hell how do
you even describe what just happened
you missed
uh
oh man that was probably the worst 20
seconds of anything I've ever seen
oh just wait you said it gets worse than
this uh no way all right imagine going
to see a live live stand-up show and the
comedian pulls out memes from 2010 out
of his back pocket and unfolds them on
like color printed paper and explains
the meme to the room and it takes 15
minutes to explain it to the room but
you got it in five seconds right and
then it like showed a hut that said [ __ ]
yeah it was just yeah it was a it was a
bathroom and the logo said [ __ ] coin on
it and then it zoomed in and the toilet
paper was the American dollar
Jesus Christ
that's kind of what I hate about some
crypto peoples they're so self-righteous
oh dude you're you're [ __ ] investing
in these you know institutions that have
been around for forever you're just
building the dollar for these old men
that owns yeah dude they own everything
dude they own everything you know if
these guys wanted to they could just
wake up tomorrow and like try as hard as
they could but yeah um remember that
environments that you guys care about
yeah we're just gonna build like a a
crypto mining gestapo yeah they're just
gonna run around finding people who mind
crypto you know what I mean like they
can do that yeah you guys can't do that
it's also what's funny is that like
crypto tanked Bitcoin went down like 39
or something like that for the people
that like have their net worth in
Bitcoin that's [ __ ] insane your net
worth it just halved yeah on November
12th Odell Beckham Jr signed a deal with
the Rams worth 750k He announced he
would take that in Bitcoin uh Bitcoin at
the time was 64k today it's worth 35k so
that deal is now worth 412 okay right we
had to pay taxes on the 750k which
federal and state taxes in California at
that level is 50.3 percent so that means
as of now he's netted 35 000 from the
one year Rams contract this year
now let's get a little more coin face
sir
the lambo is ready
yeah that's not a Lambo that is
literally a car from autopia in
California Adventure yeah seriously what
the [ __ ] I'd be livid if I was in the
metaverse and they're like your lambo's
ready and it's that [ __ ] clown car
did it hit a wall yeah
[Music]
entering the blockchain hills hey what's
that the Vladimir Club crypto lenders
members only club we are preparing
everything for tonight we are throwing
the most epic crypto party ever I wonder
who your plus one is going to be here we
are King crypto lenders territory and
here you have the 60 Parcels I can't
wait to get to mine
oh my god wow
pretty sick spot
honestly worth honestly seg view dope
rug that's a bear rug also look at the
art and he's got a crypto Punk dude he's
got a crypto Punk
um now just just real quick uh
does the person who edited this video
actually have the rights to that crypto
Punk to display it in that space that's
a good question you're not supposed to
do that yeah that's a good question
build something dope for vacations but
now that I'm here I might never leave I
already see we're gonna have the time of
our lives show me more okay
first stop of the tour this was on the
top of the list a much requested working
Zone
okay let's just [ __ ] have everyone
jacking off watching porn first of all
there's so many things here why would
they create a building called the Hub
dude also what's so funny is all right
so VR right that's the whole point of
this to want to use VR you're like a
certain person okay okay you're just a
you're a certain Target demo and this
[ __ ] already exists like VR chat is so
many worlds ahead of what the metaverse
is right in every way who is this
targeting like the metaverse and Krypton
all this [ __ ] this is just like all one
big [ __ ] timeshare scam but just in
different ways you know it's a picture
it's you know it's pictures of monkeys
it's [ __ ] these digital literal
timeshares like it's all just that yeah
and and it's sad thinking about
someone's dad being like I saw this
[ __ ] I was watching the the
um the playoff games for the NFL on
Sunday they had these [ __ ] crypto
commercials and I was like what poor guy
is just drunk rooting for the [ __ ]
Kansas City Chiefs and he sees this FTX
commercial he's like oh my goodness
crypto he just dumps all his
construction money into that next day it
craters yeah it goes to [ __ ] yeah 50
of what he put in devastating yeah and
you got some [ __ ] who comes along
he's like oh it's because you put in the
wrong thing put in the picture of this
monkey and it'll come back
get familiarized I don't wanna leave
[Music]
Burn It Down